some so let's look forward obviously
coinbase today and I pressured caveat
this entire conversation we have some
exposure to coinbase financially we're
not direct investors in the company but
basically we've invested in somebody
who's invested in the company but where
do they go from here right in terms of
they it's an eight plus billion dollar
company based on public reports but do
they continue to stay private forever do
they have aspirations to go public
do they tokenize the company's equity I
think one time Brian said something
about you know that would be like the
most coin based thing to do I'm kind of
what's the conversation around the
company from that standpoint you know
insiders told me the plan was to go
public this year but you know like
everything else then pandemic you know
life is on hold you know and but unlike
so many other unicorns I mean they are
you know profitable most quarters so
they can and I think you put your finger
on it the question is not you know if or
when is how and I talked to Fredersen
recently and you know asked him this
like what's it gonna look like are you
gonna do a blockchain token and he said
yeah I'd be pretty boring if we just did
a conventional Nasdaq IPO and I think
there's so many people because they are
you know a lot of people hate coinbase
but you know they're they're the
industry leader they're the standard
bearer for the industry so I think could
be very brutally disappointing if they
just did something boring so I think
it's just how much you know how quickly
looking at the regular toy ducks in a
row and you know what I hear in the
companies they want to do some hybrid
listing of you know they'll float some
shares like normal but also put a bunch
of those on a token and do you know
these sort of a ICO meets IPO and I
can't wait to see the details and that's
what they hope to do but who knows I
mean maybe their investors will get
impatient and just push them out the
door but I think the crypto world is
really hoping for a you know a coin
based open yeah and it's interesting too
because I wonder if there's a day where
we see a coin base equity token trading
on coin base right was kind of leads to
the question of they historically have
listed assets that are not securities
and I think that's you know as you
mentioned kind of part of that
underwriting process and really kind of
trying to stay on the right side of the
regulator's does the company eventually
end up listing kind of commodities
currencies
insecurities all in this digital format
all in one location or how do you think
that kind of plays out based on the
conversations you've had yeah your your
that's prescient I mean I think you're
looking into the future and that's what
the future is gonna be you know I think
we're gonna see Nike and Apple stock and
other equities you know traded as tokens
because it just makes so much sense it's
so much more efficient it's more secure
who will be doing that I don't know
possibly coinbase but we could also see
you know the big broker we could see
IntercontinentalExchange trying to buy
Jam and I or coinbase and you know this
see a period where we have you know
hybrid share listings for a while but I
think no doubt you know I you know I
don't know what your guess is I'd say
maybe within ten years we'll see that
yeah look I I personally my personal
opinion is that we will see stocks bonds
currencies and commodities all digitized
right kind of technology layer will be
the same and it just generally makes
sense we're kind of seeing this right if
you take some of the companies we see
that are focused on like millennial
investing and things like that they're
trying to put various asset classes
together on the same platform that's a
little bit different but but still
directionally getting towards where you
could buy Bitcoin buy a stock or buy
something else all in one location
it just seems that's the way the future
is gonna play out but I don't know right
yeah I mean technology is inevitable you
know remember we had the internet when
we realized things were gonna go digital
you know and they logically should
happen next year in some industries it
took them 20 years and you know but I
just can't see going backwards this
stuff just makes so much sense but who's
gonna do it I don't know will will Quinn
base morph into become the you know New
York Stock Exchange the future where
they get acquired you know and then also
the other people big in this game is you
know Facebook with their Libra token you
know I think it's noble that Apple and
Amazon we're gonna start tokenizing
stuff - you know there's government
central banks it's it's kind of a jump
ball out there but I think you're
absolutely right all this is going to
happen but who's gonna pull it off first
I don't know yeah I think it was 2017
maybe I tweeted and I said look you know
within the next 24 months we're gonna
get large companies start to issue these
tokens and my guess was actually Tesla
and Amazon Tesla having like some sort
of energy
for the the grid right so you actually
have some incentive mechanism that
that's used there and then Amazon just
from the idea that a gift card is
basically a token right I mean yeah it's
a different technology form factor and
so you can easily see kind of this
happening but I do think that it's
happened slower than people have thought
right it was kind of like in 17
everything was gonna happen you know
through 24 months now it's probably
pushed out a little ways well I mean if
someone's gonna build the interface the
problem with it I don't want to know
install the crypto community but I think
they're so in love with their own
technology their own culture there's
been a lag in building you know I mean
even with dphi stuff I try to cover it
and I mean this theoretically it's so
cool but I mean you want me to get it
you know browser add-on and meta masks
and all the rest of it and I mean give
me a break this stuff has got to be you
know an app it's got to be easy to use
as any other app on my phone and that's
where I think the big corporates could
have a role I think Amazon you know
Tesla yes given their unique corporate
culture could do that but you know I
mean we need those user interfaces and
it's just seems a lot of crypto
sometimes is insider compressing each
other with who can build the most you
know kind of out there technically
sophisticated products and we got to
remember you know most people this stuff
is just too hard you got to build it so
it's accessible the UI is so crucial and
you know I think you got to build a
plumbing first and that's what's going
on but you know who's gonna crack the
code and make this mainstream accessible
I don't know could be coinbase could be
Tesla could be Amazon could be Apple
could be Facebook or some incumbent or
some startup out there who's gonna solve
this all but I can't wait to see how it
turns out yeah I mean look corn based
gemenon I think part of what's made
those companies so successful ROS they
basically made it look very similar to
other brokerage type products right and
so if you're if you're used to kind of
buying financial assets on a platform
you now can do it here and they make it
look and feel very user friendly but
then you also have things like cash app
right that are just you know stupid
simple and they're kind of pulling other
people in I wonder what other trends I'm
kind of going with and coinbase to
finish up and you've covered you know
crypto for a while now and obviously
seeing everything from the early stays
to now what are the other trends that
are interesting to you mission defy but
are there other things that it's gonna
stick out to you or that you're paying
attention to
it's assistants side you mentions
cashout square I Sutton do a VC recently
just described as a beast and dorsey's
interest in crypto and the
infrastructure they're building and
subtle but I mean they've got a a giant
banking network you know so they there
wants to watch that would be really neat
if they push the crypto ball forward I
could see them doing that for sure you
know otherwise I think the thing to
watch right now is what comes out of the
crisis we've seen with the you know
attempts to deliver funds you know to to
businesses you know and within the last
crisis in 2008 and 2009
you know we saw legislation that enable
the whole FinTech industry to take off
the PayPal's and things like that so I'm
watching to see if the lawmakers are
smart enough to do something to to
facilitate how things are going to
change you know I think the way we pay
is changing you know like I'm Canadian
I'm surprised that the u.s. still
doesn't you know have contactless
payments you know Canada's had that for
years you know everywhere else Asia's
miles ahead and you know it might take
this health crisis to get people to stop
swiping credit cards you know so I'm
curious lot of the innovations in us the
world is gonna come into America and I'm
always surprised about how cultural
payment is just you know people pay very
differently in Northern Europe and in
Asia and Canada and America so you know
obviously crypto is gonna have a role to
play in that as well
I'm watching Facebook entry you know
closely because I think that that notion
of I know a lot of people hate it
because it's centralized it's not real
crypto that's true but I think the more
people get familiar with this with
tokens with you know fungible wallets
you know let's just get everyone on the
platform and then educate them about you
know having their own hardware wallet
and stuff so sorry that's kind of a
stream of consciousness answer but
that's some of the things I'm looking at
and finally central banks to you know I
think you know are they going to you
know we're gonna see you know what's is
China going to pull this off can you do
it without turning to a surveillance
mechanism I think that's going to be a
big story in the next couple years